you
[Music]
it's the 1940s the height of World War
two Rochester New York a chemist by the
name of Harry Coover's conducting
research for Eastman Kodak he and his
team are looking for a clear plastic to
produce precision gun sights for the
military they begin working with a
family of chemicals called
cyanoacrylates but find to their extreme
annoyance that the chemicals stick to
everything permanently the
cyanoacrylates are discarded after the
war Hoover is working at Codex chemical
plants in Tennessee this time he and his
team are researching heat-resistant
polymers for jet airplane canopies they
try cyanoacrylates but find to their
great frustration that the chemicals
stick to everything permanently again
the cyanoacrylates are discarded Coover
however in a moment of vision realizes
that the quality that makes these
chemicals so infuriating to work with is
exactly what makes them valuable he
takes out a patent and begins marketing
a super glue years later during the
Vietnam War field medics find that using
super glue on an open wound instantly
stops the bleeding saving countless
lives today medical grade super glue is
still used in surgery but it's also a
nearly indispensable household item
you
[Music]